A small seed falls to the ground and becomes buried in the soft soil.
The seed is buried in the soft soil, and the rain falls.
The rain soaks into the soil that holds the small seed.
The small seed soaks up water from the rain.
The water feeds the seed, and roots grow down deep into the soil.
The leaves and a stem grow up through the ground.
The leaves gather in the sunshine.
The plant uses sunshine to make food.
The rain and the soil feed the small plant.
The plant grows taller, and more leaves grow on the stem.
The roots grow longer.
They go deep in the ground.
The big plant grows flowers.
The flowers make seeds.
A new seed falls into the soft soil.
What will happen next?